When I take magnesium and the super allo, I have too many bowel movements the next day,
what should I do?
So understand for those who don't know, the super allo product is a brand name of orthomolecular.
And it is the allo, it's called the, it's called cape allo.
So it's not allo, our residents are allo, burber residents that would be used to help stimulate
immune system function, cape allo is used to help stimulate bowel movements, it's a different
type of allo.
That's what super allo is, so the only reason one would take super allo is if they have
issues with bowel movements, they have a history of constipation or something like that.
So if you are taking magnesium and super allo and you're having too many bowel movements,
you're in the bathroom all the next day, then you got to admit one of them.
I would say you omit the super allo first magnesium, the way magnesium works to help stimulate
bowel movements is it simply works by drawing water into the large intestine because if you
take too much magnesium, so understand magnesium is a mineral and it's a cofactor in about 700
different metabolic processes in your body, it's very necessary for your body magnesium
is an often overlooked deficiency in people's lives because it's a cofactor in so many metabolic
processes, it's a good idea for everybody to be taking magnesium.
How much magnesium do you need for all these metabolic processes?
Well the truth is not very much, maybe only 100 milligrams.
So if you take more than that, like some people will take 400 milligrams before they go
to bed or 1000 milligrams before they go to bed, maybe that's too much, but if they have
constipation issues, magnesium can be beneficial because if you take too much, you don't really
overdose on magnesium, you'll dump it into the small intestine or the large intestine and
because it's an ion, it will draw water.
So it draws water into the large intestine and then you'll have elusive bowel's the next
day.
So many people start taking magnesium just to help with bowel movements so they'll take
a protocol call or they'll take a magnesium supplement before they go to bed and they'll
have nice bowel movements the next day and that works just fine, but some people that are
really constipated need more help than just magnesium.
So again, magnesium works by just drawing water, so you got to make sure you're not dehydrated
at the same time or magnesium is not going to work at all.
Secondly, still you might have issues with contraction of the intestinal muscles and you've
taken something like superalo, which is again the capealo or taking some seda or something
like that is necessary for some people that have a chronic constipation issues they've
had for their lifetime.
But then once you start having a bowel movement, maybe you don't need superalo anymore.
So typically I tell people to take superalo only when they need to like, oh my gosh, I didn't
have a bowel movement today, I feel so bloated and it's now four o'clock in the afternoon.
Well maybe tonight take a superalo with your magnesium and see how that works.
But typically, this is not always the case, but typically people use superalo in that way,
they're only using it as needed and they won't be taking it on a daily basis.
Now there are exceptions, I have some people that have to take superalo every single day or
they won't have a bowel movement, they're not in the bathroom six times, they just don't
have a good bowel movement the next day, they need to take it.
There's other issues, neurological issues, et cetera, with their intestinal transit time
and superalo is the thing that works for them.
And the question is, I'm taking superalo and magnesium activity moments next day, I
would omit the superalo, see how you do with just the magnesium, make sure that you're
drinking enough water and then only use the superalo as needed.